Transcription: Mandy Vincent
Relecteur: eric vautier
Assis au bord d'un monde en plein doute,
Cœur et Raison se demandaient quoi faire
en regardant l'espace noir et profond
au bout de leurs pieds.
« Tu vois, Cœur, j’ai tourné ces
questions en boucle dans ma tête,
et ailleurs, ce n’est guère mieux »,
affirme Raison d’un ton un peu épuisé.
Cœur lui répond, taquin :
« Qu'en sais-tu, tu n'y es jamais allé !
On est face à l'inconnu.
Moi, si je ferme les yeux,
tends les oreilles,
j’ouvre mes pores et surtout,
(Elle inspire)
si je flaire autour, tout me dit
que c’est bien, là-dessous !
Nous pouvons sauter ! »
Et vous, que faites-vous dans
ce monde bourré d’informations,
pour décider ce qu'il faut faire ou pas ?
À qui faire confiance.
Choisir le bon chemin.
Avoir du flair.
Faites-vous plutôt appel à
votre raison ou à vos ressentis ?
« Suivre son nez »,
« Ce qui nous pend au nez »,
« Comme le nez au milieu de la figure »,
sont autant d'expressions
qui en disent beaucoup
sur le pouvoir de ce sens.
Pourtant depuis longtemps,
on l’a considéré comme un sens annexe
pour la survie des humains.
On le redécouvre depuis 2004,
année où le prix Nobel
de médecine et de physiologie
a été octroyé à Linda Buck
et Richard Axel.
Ces chercheurs ont réussi à interpréter
comment les récepteurs olfactifs
décodent les odeurs
et comment les neurones olfactifs
envoient l'information
d'abord vers le cerveau limbique,
siège de nos émotions,
vers Cœur en premier,
puis vers la partie néocortex
du cerveau qui les conceptualise.
Parce que pour Raison,
les émotions, ça peut ressembler au chaos.
Cette reconnaissance mondiale
a ressuscité l’intérêt
pour ce sens négligé.
Depuis, on se remémore
la puissance vitale de l'olfaction,
qui est un langage chimique ancestral,
depuis l'unicellulaire, la paramécie,
dont témoigne le spermatozoïde
qui, grâce à ses récepteurs olfactifs,
peut nager efficacement vers l'ovule.
Cette forme de langage a été conservée,
entre tous les êtres vivants,
afin d’assurer leur survie dans la nature.
Même chez l'être humain moderne,
l'odorat reste un sens essentiel
de la communication non verbale.
« Ne pas pouvoir sentir quelqu’un »,
comme dit l’expression.
Des expériences montrent d'ailleurs
que nos odeurs peuvent communiquer
à notre insu nos émotions,
comme par exemple l’odeur de la peur
via la molécule de cortisol
dans la transpiration,
ou encore l'odeur de la tristesse
transmise par les larmes.
Lorsque les gens perdent l’odorat,
lorsqu’il y a anosmie -
et combien de personnes ont fait
cette douloureuse expérience
ces derniers temps -
les gens deviennent très déprimés
dans 80 % des cas.
Ils ont alors la sensation
d'être hors du monde.
Nous-mêmes, confinés devant nos écrans,
nous ressentons assez vite cette sensation
d'être déconnecté de la réalité.
Parce que sans inférence sensorielle,
sans émotions,
il n’y a rien qui distingue
un événement d’un autre
et nous n’ancrons donc plus de souvenirs.
Respirer et ressentir,
c'est se sentir vivant.
Tout ceci nous montre à quel point
nous tous, les êtres humains,
nous sommes des êtres sensibles,
que notre équilibre se situe
au carrefour des sens.
Pourtant, bien que nous baignions
à tout moment dans les odeurs,
nous n'y prêtons généralement
pas attention.
Et vous ?
Quelle est votre relation
avec votre odorat ?
Touchons notre nez
et prenons une grande inspiration.
Laissons l’odeur pénétrer en nous.
Que sentons-nous ?
Quelle est l'odeur de votre voisin ?
Qu'est-ce que cela vous fait ?
Quelles pensées vous viennent ?
Je suis une parfumeuse scientifique,
artiste, convaincue du pouvoir des odeurs.
Cela fait plus de 20 ans que je jongle
avec mes différentes compétences
afin d'installer des odeurs
partout où on ne les attend pas.
Le métier de parfumeur, d'abord,
consiste à mélanger des matières odorantes
afin de produire une création
qui est elle-même une odeur nouvelle.
Afin de comprendre
le rôle des ingrédients,
nous réalisons des milliers de mélanges.
C'est vraiment un métier d'expérience.
Ceci nous permet ensuite
de choisir les composants
en fonction de l'effet désiré.
Nous inscrivons leurs noms
avec une quantité en grammes
sur chaque ligne.
C'est comme une recette,
c'est notre formule.
Lorsqu’on crée un parfum,
on cherche la plupart du temps
à apporter du bien-être aux gens.
Je me souviens au début
de ma carrière de parfumeur,
dans une société industrielle,
nous testions dans différents pays
des nouveaux parfums que
nous avions créés pour des lessives,
et ceci en utilisant notamment
les molécules d’aldéhydes
qui connotent la sensation
de propre sur le linge.
Et nous avons pu le constater
à maintes reprises,
le propre, ça fait se sentir bien.
Je me souviens aussi de ce projet
de retrouver l'odeur de sa grand-mère
pour une cliente qui tenait
son souvenir de ses cinq ans.
Nous avons passé beaucoup de temps
à recréer le parfum de Finou,
le petit nom de Joséphine,
en rassemblant l’odeur de sa maison,
de son jardin, du linge,
de sa cuisine et de ses bras aimants.
Ce qui m'exaspère particulièrement
aujourd'hui, c'est que le parfum
soit utilisé comme un banal objet de
consommation pour le prêt-à-porter,
la cosmétique ou le neuromarketing.
Il m'est aussi tout à fait inacceptable
que l'on interdise de plus en plus
d'ingrédients dans les parfums,
surtout les ingrédients naturels,
sans que l'on prenne en compte
les effets positifs importants
qu'ils peuvent avoir sur nos vies.
C'est pourquoi,
en tant qu'artiste des odeurs,
je m’évade de cette démarche commerciale.
Je ne veux pas conditionner,
je souhaite libérer.
Inventer et faire vivre
des expériences artistiques olfactives
m’est apparu important afin de susciter
chez un maximum de personnes
la conscience du nez,
telle que je la vis au quotidien
dans mon travail des parfums.
Car la première chose qui m'a choquée
en rentrant dans ce métier,
en venant du monde de la science
et des théories rationnelles,
était de devoir créer
quelque chose qui ne se voit pas.
Être parfumeur,
c'est rentrer dans l'invisible,
c'est apprendre à imaginer des odeurs,
à former des images mentales
qui inspirent la création.
Créer un parfum, c’est apprendre à écouter
comment cela résonne à l’intérieur
comme dans les cérémonies du Kôdô au Japon
où l'on s'entraîne à apprécier
des effluves évanescents.
Concentré sur ce petit récipient
contenant de la cendre réchauffant
délicatement un bout de bois précieux,
les gestes calibrés et précis.
Ce sont alors des arômes complexes,
vanillés, épicés, voire marins,
qui viennent effleurer les narines
et allumer des visions
d'estampes japonaises
que l’on contemple avec
conscience dans le silence.
Être parfumeur,
c’est en somme entretenir
un dialogue constant à l’intérieur
entre les ressentis, le cœur,
le cerveau limbique, l’inspiration
et la réflexion,
la raison,
le néocortex, la structuration
afin de définir l'équilibre subtil
entre différentes notes olfactives
dans la formule.
Écouter sa voix intérieure
fait donc partie intégrante
du chemin de création
comme un rail invisible
qui guide une idée.
C'est ce que les parfums m'ont appris
et que je partage avec de nombreux
étudiants en quête d'innovation.
C'est cette voix intérieure
que je cherche à stimuler
dans mes installations olfactives.
Car s'écouter est inspirant pour créer
mais aussi pour faire des choix
qui ont du sens dans nos vies.
J'invite ainsi chacun à dialoguer
avec sa partie humaine sensible
qui peut être touchée
si profondément par les parfums.
Pour ce faire, je crée seule
ou en collaboration
avec des artistes de théâtre,
des conteurs, des conteuses,
des plasticiens, des médecins,
tous mus par la même quête humaniste
des odeurs expérimentales
pour leurs domaines d'exploration.
Ce sont ainsi des atmosphères
de mousse de chêne et de sous-bois,
aussi bien que des effluves abstraits
de bêtes ou de fantômes poussiéreux
qui rentrent dans les pièces de théâtre,
dans les musées, dans l'art contemporain,
dans les galeries d'art,
afin que ce sens vive autant que
les autres et emporte nos imaginaires.
Nous avons aussi créé entre artistes
des dialogues d'essences,
des installations
artistiques multi-sensorielles
imbriquant intimement musique,
peinture et parfum en cohérence.
À chaque fois,
les gens restent immobiles,
comme s’ils étaient téléportés ailleurs.
Ils nous disent ensuite qu’ils
ont vécu comme un rêve éveillé.
C'est comme si une étincelle de magie
s'allumait au carrefour des sens
qui fait voyager sans se déplacer.
Aujourd’hui, la docteur Catherine Bernard,
à l’hôpital Bicêtre APHP de Paris,
teste des créations olfactives
afin de rééduquer la multi-sensorialité
de patients restés très longtemps
sous respirateur artificiel.
Elle nous relate que pour ses patients,
les odeurs associées
à des séances d’immersion virtuelle
leur permettent de relâcher
leurs angoisses,
de revenir vraiment dans le monde,
de respirer pleinement.
On peut dire que les odeurs
associées à la réalité virtuelle
peuvent redonner goût à la vie.
Mesdames et messieurs,
cet organe qui est là au milieu du visage,
nous amène à ressentir
un état de perception
qui nous a permis de survivre
dans le monde sauvage
mais avec lequel nous avons
perdu une intime connexion
après une petite centaine
d’années de pur rationalisme.
Soyons fous et réexplorons ce sens oublié.
Les parfums nous apprennent que
nous avons cette intelligence sensorielle
ce cœur, ce Q.E.
qui peut nous aider à penser
et à agir avec notre Q.I., notre raison,
qui ensemble, nourrissent
notre petite voix unique à chacun.
En les réunissant, nous réapprenons
à respecter notre humanité
dans toutes nos sensibilités
et toute notre diversité,
à faire grandir ce qui nous rend unique
pour pouvoir nous lancer
avec cœur dans l'inconnu.
Sautons dans notre partie invisible.
Oubliez votre visage,
votre nom, votre métier.
(Battements de cœur)
Concentrez-vous sur cette partie
de vous qui est là, à l’intérieur,
entre la tête, les tripes et le cœur.
Laissez-vous porter.
Rien ne peut vous arriver.
Vous êtes avec vous-même.
(Elle inspire)
Sentez et ressentez.
Merci.
(Applaudissements)